I sincerely hope that this is the first
and last time that I get to see a Steve
Carell in an outfit like this never
again the incredible Burt Wonderstone
stars Steve Carell Steve Buscemi Jim
Carrey Alan Arkin and Olivia Wilde as
well as James Gandolfini this movie is
like The Prestige the comedy version it
is the story of dueling magicians of all
different types Steve Buscemi and Steve
Carell now these guys are friends they
grew up together they discovered magic
together when they were kids the film
opens with them getting their first
magic kit and they become friends then
all of a sudden just cuts to them and
now they're adults and they're running
this incredibly cheesy magic show in
which they dance and make people
disappear put swords through doors while
people are inside you know all that kind
of stuff this is where they meet Olivia
Wilde's character who becomes their
assistant in the magic show Jim Carrey
is kind of like the Criss Angel
Mindfreak type he's the guy who stands
out on the street and crowds watch him
and he sticks nails in his head and he
sets himself on fire and walks on hot
coals he's not really a magician per se
he basically does bodily harm stuff but
the fact is Burt Wonderstone show ain't
really drawn a crowd anymore because
everyone wants to go see Jim Carrey
perform this starts a big rivalry
between these guys and now we have our
comedy now I like virtually all of the
talent involved with this film
I've enjoyed Steve Carell in the past I
think he's a funny guy I've loved Steve
Buscemi in various films Jim Carrey is
one of my favorite comedians from the
90s I grew up with that guy watching
every comedy he did laughing my butt off
until I was crying and I was excited to
see this movie simply because of that
talent but I gotta say this movie really
isn't that funny and that's very sad for
me to say see when a movies trying to be
funny like this movie is it needs to
have characters that you can at least
relate to in some way or like and I
think the problem with this movie
honestly is the characters you have to
have really likeable characters for a
comedy to work and in this movie Steve
Carell character and Steve Buscemi's
character are two of the most unlikable
people I've seen in movies so far this
year this is a trend lately in movies
where characters are just absolute jerks
like in 21 and over and for some reason
we're supposed to like these guys and
relate to them and they do the same
thing with Steve Carell is character in
this movie because it takes forever for
you to get any real
attachment to him and I kind of just
loathe his character for a large portion
of this movie and I had a hard time
laughing in anything he did because it
was just kind of like insulting random
people that's worked in the past in some
movies but it just didn't work here and
poor Steve Buscemi has nothing to do in
this movie he is completely outweighed
comically by everyone around him and he
just did not fit in with this movie and
I like Steve Buscemi but like every joke
he said just completely failed it wasn't
funny and he just didn't fit in in this
movie at all there was a saving grace
for me in this movie though and that was
Jim Carrey that man is hilarious still
he is great in this movie and I found
myself actually begging for him to come
back onto the screen whenever his
character was gone because he is a
supporting character in this movie
whenever he comes on the screen he's got
like this new wild crazy stunt and
they're all hilarious because Jim Carrey
is actually really funny and he played a
likeable unlikable guy that was what
Steve Carell should have been going for
and I found myself actually rooting for
Jim Carrey more often than I did Carell
even though Carrie's technically the
villain in this movie now as I said
eventually Carol's character starts to
have this persona where I should change
in blah blah blah and everything is
beautiful sunshine and rainbows after
that happened you started to kind of
like his character more when alan arkin
scare achter who is also good in this
film as well as introduced he was also
the kind of jerk character who's like
leave me alone I don't want to talk to
you and blah blah blah I'm old now leave
me alone he was a likable jerk and
that's what this movie had unfortunately
a lot of problems with all of the
characters were jerks but only a few of
them were actually likable jerks and it
kind of seemed like the director and the
screenwriter were like giving every
single actor some joke bit and some of
these actors just don't do joke bits
like James Gandolfini's in this movie
who was a very good actor but when he's
trying to do these Adam Sandler like
jokes it just didn't work and the same
goes for the inclusion of jay mohr in
this movie and i don't even know what
he's doing it was painful okay because i
was at an advanced screening of this
film and the theater was like a hundred
percent full like almost every seat
filled and jay Moore's on screen telling
jokes and there was literally not even a
chuckle amongst the entire like 400
people in this theater it was kind of
sad
so from a comedy standpoint the film
succeeds whenever Carrie's on screen
there are a few jokes that Carell does
that are good I like him I don't dislike
him he just his character in this movie
was so unlikable Steve Buscemi
unfortunately I don't really think he
should have been in this movie to be
honest he just felt completely out of
place cliches were abundant and the
direction of the film felt extremely
lazy nothing in this movie really felt
like it was worthy of the talent
involved with it there are jokes in this
movie that are good there are lines in
this movie that are good and most of
them are from Carrie or Arkin so I would
suggest seeing this movie for those two
actors alone Jim Carrey's great Alan
Arkin is great but everyone else was
kind of a letdown so I'm gonna give the
incredible Burt Wonderstone a seat so
I'd like to know what is your favorite
Jim Carrey comedy because he's done some
serious work as well my favorite comedy
of his would probably be liar liar I
think that movie is like endlessly
hilarious almost like every scene is
comic gold thanks a lot as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my knives
[Music]